this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised hello hello and welcome to your
live Safari experience that happens
every day twice a day except for this
morning
where we had a morning off and we thank
you for your patience in that my name is
Jaime and this afternoon Archie is on
camera with me and we are live from the
Masai Mara in Kenya we will also be
joined by our Salah African crew once
they manage to a change a tire and be
get out on foot a little bit later oh it
is a blisteringly hot afternoon and they
say that filming live wildlife is
something of a gamble and I have to tell
you that these elephants have not rolled
the dice in my favor
I don't know if you could say that they
did that's a bit of a weird mixed
metaphor but they decided to walk away
to the other side of the road and have
now moved really far away so you will
just have to join me as we trend along
but for our new viewers who have just
discovered this live stream it gives me
an opportunity to tell you that not only
is this live but you can ask questions
just to prove it's live so if you don't
believe me you can ask a question on the
YouTube comments or on hashtag Safari
live on Twitter if you feel so inclined
a bitter remove that brite bottle of
suntan lotion remove that away what's my
mistake sorry so that is how you can get
hold of us obviously you don't just have
to ask us questions if you don't believe
we're live you can also ask us questions
about what we are seeing and in fact
that is your greatest chance of having
your questions sent through and said out
live now said it's a blisteringly hot
day initially it was the weather
stations seem to suggest it was 22
degrees Fahrenheit which is about 72 ish
it's not it's about 28 which for the
Mara is
warm 28 equates to 82 Fahrenheit it is
still far hotter now in South Africa but
it's plenty warm Oh windy for the Maasai
Mara the weather has gone back to its
usual style of storming in the
afternoons Carol you want to know if
there's any news on waffles today now I
was going to do an entire Drive
dedicated to the migration which is well
and truly arrived over there and I'll
still do most of that but Carol wants to
know about waffles I want to know about
waffles because I haven't gone to see
the waffle 'its since yesterday
morning's end of the gauntlet series so
I'm deeply concerned about the little
waffle its Carol 6 Carol 6 am I getting
that right Carol 6 sticks
I don't know if I've suddenly lost my
ability to hear names drivers fast
asleep gifts of or taking photos of the
eighties and he is fast asleep from this
front seat
oh sweet look at these ILI's over here
you block up the entire road quickly
always ins well especially in high
season having a little push backwards
and forwards and the little one would
like to join in as well please thank you
very much I will go and see the little
waffle it's today and if for new viewers
that means little spotted hyenas waffles
is the name of a hyena this is wonderful
the ball and what actually looks like a
cow mitt really not that must be a ball
no it was two balls and a youngster who
just got involved in the whole process
the light is so blindingly bright right
now at this time of the afternoon it's
almost hard to tell just really I mean
the shape of that phorid looks like a
cow no it is it's a cow she's just had
him she's just urinated and maybe she
has a bit of an infliction as well
there's a car interesting she was saying
hello to the big ball that tried to
intimidate us earlier didn't work but I
let him save face
now I'm going to go and find you a
couple of wildebeest and by a couple I
mean a couple of wildebeest
however Sydney has beaten me to it I
have put a head of dwelt abased here and
where I am I can see that the wind is
blowing too much which is very much
difficult for me to hear what is
happening a very very good afternoon and
welcome to the beginning of our guy
Network I am Sydney and I'm not
traveling alone this afternoon
I am with my camera operator Dave and we
are going to try by all ways to give you
the best experience ever for questions
and comments you can follow us on
Twitter hashtag safari life you can also
follow us on YouTube chat stream look at
this world of this very nicely relaxed
the weather condition is about 33
degrees it's quite very hot at the
moment here where I am and it's
punctuated with quite a lot of wind this
world is now might be enjoying some
rumination as well the beasts a part of
those animals which are ruminants Rubens
I'm talking about the animals which
normally goes out for feeding purposes
and when the Sun is very hot like this
is when they are going to have a chance
lie under trees and bring back food to
the mouth and chew some card which is a
very interesting adaptation because it
does help them in order to prevent loss
of water from the body because they
don't have to feed all day long I just
got together a lot of food early in the
mornings when it's hot is time to eat a
very same food again
thank you very very much for a hot
welcome back yes indeed I enjoyed my
live it was too short but I really
enjoyed the live and when I'm back now I
found that the weather is completely
different now it's getting very hot I've
got to prepare now and have some of the
clothes which will help me during this
kind of weather conditions so let's just
move a little bit further and see if we
can have a better visual of this world
waist now while I'm moving while I'm
moving much closer let's see Jameses are
also out on a game drive at the moment
maybe James does have something
interesting at the moment
one does hurt that I will have something
interesting imma stop shouting at you
good morning good afternoon good evening
wherever you happen to be in the world
different times of the day of course my
name is James Henry and we are
approaching a spot where Hasan of the
male leopard there is Dingaan of the
male leopard right in front of us note
in Ghana there he is
he stole a meal from his son hasana
yesterday and we're just going to see if
we can't get a few of both of them once
very nice okay that's a good start now
we have something of an embarrassment of
riches today because there were wild
dogs as well on the reserve there were
lions on chitra which is another reserve
we're allowed to go to so I thought we'd
start with the lion or the leopards and
then sort of decide from there where we
might like to go can you see the other
lipid anywhere I did see this one having
a bit of a growl making me think that
perhaps the Sun was around I'm just
gonna maneuver through here as I tell
you of course it would love to hear from
you on the Sunday afternoon you can use
the hashtag safari light you can use the
chat stream on YouTube and I think
there's the only two ways you can talk
to us I used to make the hilarious joke
that's sending us a written letter by
post would be a waste of time because
the South African postal service is so
terribly poor and that has not changed
please also do not send a fax we do not
deal with faxes
ease up here we are quite close to him
so I just need to be quite sensitive to
how close we get and how much noise we
make around him and of course make sure
that we don't nearly run over or sauna
somewhere punch crunch crunch
tell me when you've got a look at his
face focus should have now yes now once
we've had a look at in Ghana I'm pretty
sure that husana is around here
somewhere the reason I chose to come
here first was because it's well it's
going to be in the shade really just
gonna ease forward a little there we go
there's his face it's in the shade and
it was fairly guaranteed because up in
the tree to the left of us we can see
the carcass bonny identifying different
lipids can be difficult and this you
know the area quite well we know this
area very well we know that the lipids
here are territorial of course they're
territorial everywhere and so if we find
a male leopard in this area well then
we're pretty sure as to who it is you
can quickly gauge the age but also it's
just like you can recognize your own pet
we see them so often that when we saw
this leopard immediately it was obvious
it was 10 Ghana he's got a big fat head
he's got a dewlap which is the loose bit
of skin that hangs beneath his throat
and it was just obviously him and what
he did was he stole that niala kill from
his son yesterday I'm pretty sure his
son will be here somewhere and I said
just listen to some rustling in the
bushes I said that he looked like he
might be growling when we got up here
and I wondered if a sauna his son wasn't
trying to get towards the tree to have a
small Sunday afternoon snack I don't see
him anywhere at this stage but it's very
hot out here and so it's not very
surprising all righty we'll have a look
around for husana while we do that let's
get back to Sydney and his wielding
beast uns
I am still enjoying a very lovely
sighting of the world best year the
whole head is just standing there
looking at us filling them so when
looking at them I can easily distinguish
between the male and females if we can
look at this one one in front of the
screen now is a female the females they
have got a brown forehead and the one on
the right if you look at the forehead
nicely you will see that it does have a
black forehead so that is how we can
easily distinguish between the male and
the female well that is the one which is
moving the head now is the male and the
one standing on the left is a female so
you can see the stripes clearly that is
why this animal is called a Bendrick no
brindle is just a term meaning the
stripes it's like a striped goo it's so
very interesting to see that the world
based here at their own normally this
kind of animals you see them working
together with other animals mostly their
best friend is the Zebras today they
don't have zebras and one of the reasons
why they join other animals is their
poor eyesight so I don't know how they
are figuring it out today as they are
working as a family without any other
species involved but to me it seems like
the
you have a good side because they are
giving some of the warning calls looking
at the direction where I come from now
we can see if in Mara the Blue Valley
beasts are doing same as the world based
in so we see your wildebeest tumor and
we raise you a couple of hundred
thousand or so I think it's safe to say
that the migration late as it is as well
and truly arrived in the Mara triangle
now it's not fair to compare of course
because this is what the Masai Mara one
of the things that the Masai Mara is a
famous for at this time of year the mass
movement of around about one and a half
a million wildebeest moving from a
Tanzania into the Maasai Mara itself you
will notice if you are new to these
viewings that there is a subtle
difference between the wildebeests that
Sydney has been creeping up to and the
Volta beast that we see here and that is
because these are as subspecies and they
have white beards impressive little
difference there are still blue builder
beasts but they have little white beards
which i think is a very attractive thing
on a Bolivian personally this was just
to give you a taster this is just a
little hint as to what I'm going to take
you to what you will notice is that they
are seriously clustered around the burn
and that's because now no it doesn't
look so good
hmmm looks a little bit thin to me a bit
Limpy well it has just had to cross the
Mara River Joe now you want to know what
the difference is between a new and a
Valle de beast they are the same thing
the new is literally the name given to a
wildebeest and it's based off a the
sound they make so what we'll do is
we'll try and get away from this
ever-present Mara wind not in any way
irritated by it and Paul we're going to
get away from the ever-present Amara
wind I'm in a pop you right in the
middle of the herd and then you can see
where the name comes from no no
no net
now pretty much continuously non-stop
so that's what I'm aiming to do these
guys they're a little bit far although I
can see them they really it's amazing
how fast it all arrives how it all
happens I just want to get you into the
main body of the hood then we'll find a
lion then we'll go see some hyenas I
think that sounds like a plan
stop blowing I should be used to it by
now
my goodness gracious so while we are
searching for large numbers of
wildebeests james's leopard sighting has
increased by one yes we've got the other
one now here is horse hana the male
leopard is even more active than his
father and as you can see is inherited
his father's superb ability to sleep
there he is he did make for kill after
all his Billy is not looking as full as
it was yesterday and so I don't think
he's had anything to eat for about 24
hours now I'd say poor fellow tristin
was just saying yesterday how it was so
amazing to watch how ting gana waited
for 20 minutes sniffing into the wind
picking something up not sure and once
he picked up on it where he thought this
thing was he walked straight here from
about two kilometers away just over a
mile and after that well there really
was nothing poor horse Anna could do
about it
now you're asking now he could tell the
difference between the two I mean if you
just saw this leopard lying again you
saw the other one lying where you saw
him you would really struggle to know
the difference unless you knew them and
the easiest way to do it in this case
would be to look at the face and just
above the whisker line there and you
would see a different spot pattern now
you can see he's got three spots just
above the whisker line there
he's got three on the other side as well
and his father has five and five so
that's a good way of telling oh my
goodness this is very impressive we're
going to go to the nest cam now with
Tristan
indeed we are James and we are with
animals that I'm sure husana is dreaming
about as he sleeps away the heat of the
days you can see a little heard of
impalas that have come in and decided to
have a little bit of a drink and quench
their thirst it is a a warm afternoon
quite windy but it's still very very
warm and
it's a perfect time of the day for him
parlors to come down and drink and I'd
imagine that they would have had a bit
of a torrid morning because from what I
gather they were wild dogs all over
around this area and so making lots and
lots of noise and so most of the impalas
I'm sure only heard that's and were
thoroughly petrified by what was going
on around them
no Impala I think likes wild dogs but if
you look at the Impala in the middle of
the frame there's a massive Impala that
is there look at the size of his horns
he really is quite an impressive
individuals who's on the left-hand side
now and I believe that today is world
dog day is that right her Sewall dog day
so that would be quite apt to have wild
dogs running around on world of dog day
hopefully we'll get lucky and we'll be
able to see them maybe coming down to
the pan for a drink if they're around
then it's a good place for them to come
and they will maybe come down and drink
they'll be quite nice now you see
there's also little baby Nala in amongst
all the impalas there's just drifting
off they go trotting away it's too much
commotion foreign Yala they like a
quieter day and quieter drinking points
then with all the hustle and bustle of
male impalas that are scattered around
everywhere but what a beautiful view it
is when you see all these animals coming
down to drinking may I help you to be a
busy Austin at the nest now while I sit
sure and wait for other things to come
down it seems you back across to Hassan
and see if James agrees that he might be
daydreaming about these guys well he is
that or niala unfortunately he lost a
niala to his daddy that maybe is
thinking about in parlors and Yala's I
think he's thinking about a great deal
right now we are going to spend very
long here because these kitties are flat
we are going to go off and see if we
can't find the wild dogs I'm told that
today is world dog day I don't know if
that means world dog in general the
entire family will domestic dog world
wolf and wild dog I'm not sure anyway I
think it would be appropriate for us to
go and see if we can find the wild dogs
from earlier this morning that is simply
because these cats are flat and we can
come back here as it cools down because
I'm sure there will be a little bit of
conflict over the kill a very
not world dog there's national dog day
in the United States well still it's a
good excuse to go and see some wild dogs
you can see what
Dingaan at least what hasana thinks of
national dog day in the United States
not very much
he's not a fan of dogs nor his father
don't like dogs at all
Schmidty yes I think there probably
would survive indeed they are extremely
adaptable leopards and you know they'll
eat anything from like I say quite often
termites all the way up to young
wildebeest and I think that as long as
they weren't killed by the hyenas and
lions of the Mara that survive very well
an example is the introduction of Tigers
to the karoon the kuru is a semi desert
region in the central parts of South
Africa and there have been various
attempts to breed Tigers in those areas
without feeding them and Tigers are
pretty good at killing local antelope
here or gazelles they kill Springville
quite successfully a heart to burst and
various other things and they adapt to
hunting in Savannah ecosystems very
easily and I imagine that with the
leopard being the most adaptable of the
big cats struggle not one jot moving
into the Mara
if you introduced one there and of
course people do introduce leopards from
time to time of let's say a leopard is
found somewhere in a an urban setting
where it might be perceived to be a
danger to human beings well then they
were might well take the leopard dart it
and introduce it to a wildlife area were
you know a long way from where it was
born and quite easily could survive so
yes I think that they would survive I
don't think it's a good idea to take
Tenggara and husana to the Mara I think
that that would be risking them rather I
think they're quite comfortable here you
can see that well Sanne doesn't look
like he needs any more of a holiday my
goodness he's looked up hang on a second
this is unbelievable
oh and he's having a stretch fixed his
claws out no maybe let's just wait here
let's see if he doesn't think about
trying to get into the tree for a snack
his father is sitting right below it
there'll be a bit of hissing and
spitting
shorty try and go towards the tree and
get into it yes you would like up the
Sunday rest wouldn't you mmm but I'm not
sure I'd like it as much as I'd like
another few minutes oh well if Dingle is
not going up there
he's doing a little bit of a chaff
towards his father the chuffing noise is
the exhalation of air quite fast
friendly and submissive exhalation of
air so what it sounds like
total ting ganas just around the corner
through this little sort of gully let's
just let this play out for a second I'm
not sure what he's gonna do I'm assure
you say go horse on a go yes I kind of
feel the same I feel like he needs a
good meal he sent me a Thanh it for a
long time yesterday I mean he had a good
he had a good 12 hours at it on his 24
hours at it on his own actually he was
arrest by some hyenas but I think
they've given up are you hungry fella
weighing up the heat of versus Li if it
oh here we go
I'm gonna move now just because I want
to be in position if he gets near the
tree naturally there are bushes placed
strategically by the elephants to make
it as difficult as possible
this is where we were yesterday for the
TV show there's the cat he's moving in
towards the kill the kill is just over
the gully to the at least that the
leopard has just over the gully to the
left here and there's the tree with the
killer net and I just want to get into a
position so that if Kangana does decide
to launch himself as his son we will see
it all right I think that will do us
from there how's that food that okay I
see the Tim there's been some here we go
dad not happy
that's very unkind
I wonder how long this has been going on
there's also no now waiting sorry about
the aerial difficult to place ourselves
in a position where both cats are in
perfect picture I was just saying it
there's been quite a lot of gardening
around here since we lived this today
if it now I can't smell the kill there's
no question that ting Garnica smelled
yesterday though it hasn't had its head
long enough to start rotting but I can't
smell it the winds blowing from this I'm
not sure why I've normally got a very
sensitive nose you can you smell it
figures nope so hoarse are not obviously
not giving up on this but I think you'll
be lucky to get a look in here I'm just
gonna shift forward slightly
sorry food I mean just shift forward
Linda can have a look at Inga an apology
so when you'll get him in a gap through
here
yeah back a bit that's fun now I guess
many people must be thinking that's very
nasty that's not very kind well
kindness ain't a big thing out here in
the wilderness and the soul boy hasn't
got to twelve years old as a dominant
male leopard of a prime piece of the
sabi sands without knowing the rules of
the wild and applying them to himself to
the greatest possible advantage and
that's what he did there
you killed it I don't care you are my
son I don't care this food is for me
that's what I care about I can get it
and so I will eat it you can go and find
something else to eat it is a harsh
attitude to take to your son one that we
as human beings probably find a little
repugnant but it's how it works out here
and therefore how it works best for
leopards you can see how much what
Brazil his faces how many more conflicts
he's experienced how many more form
bushes his ears have gone through it's
in all of you feeling very sympathetic
towards for sonna I understand that but
he's okay like I say he did feed on it
for at least 24 hours
quite interesting also I mean I think
Justin's saying yesterday that he
thought more signs probably 20 kilograms
lighter than his son here I'm not sure
as much as that but he is smaller
definitely than 10 Ghana that's horse
honor and I think that the amount of
experience of the older cat has really
does make a big difference to his
ability to dominate these interactions
he knows how to posture he feels
confident because this is his domain
this is his territory alrighty let's see
wait and see what happens out here we'll
go across the Masai Mara now where Jaime
Patterson seems to be in the thick of
the thundering hooves of the migration
herds what a phenomenal way to start off
our sunless set Safari with those are
two leopards are coming two together I
guess would be the best description we
have arrived at one of the main bodies
of the herd and I promised I would let
you listen so here you go have a listen
to exactly what it is that the bull the
beasts are saying and tell me what you
think
[Music]
this goes on so what are they saying to
each other yeah yeah Marco Polo some
giant enormous game of Marco Polo
between bull derbies it's essentially
largely the male's that make these calls
and it's cursed agrees Kirstie thinks
that it is Marco Polo one giant
wildebeest game of Marco Polo instead of
in the pool this in the long grass of
the Mara Plains with a very dangerous
added extra in that while you might be
participating in a game of Marco Polo
you might also be attracting a lion I
find I'm afraid to save all the beasts
intrinsically comic except when they're
throwing themselves off the banks of the
Mara River and breaking their limbs and
getting dashed on the rocks and drowning
and eaten by crocodiles apart from those
somewhat tragic times I find wildebeest
furious I can't help but feel any other
ways especially Kathy actually you
probably got a closer a close to call
there Kathy saying they all say like
pedestrians bottlenecking around some
roadworks busy city I know we've all
stopped why why we've all walked in a
long line in fact we're all still
walking in a long line to come and join
this group why where are you going what
I know that it's the rains and I know
that it's how this whole process works
and I know I've been here before
so please someone explain to me how they
decide where they're going to go I know
they follow the grass and all of that
that rains and then they go there and
they eat small graphs
how they decide from one part of their
day to the next
actually you know what we're gonna go
from that Ridge to that Ridge or daftar
to that Ridge with no real discernible
reason it's fascinating to watch them to
say make decisions would be a stretch
somebody's thirsty actually there's been
lots of rain no just check for
crocodiles no I think you're gonna be
okay there but the Beast that is a
really small puddle still not certain
though so I promise you it's a very
small puddle there's no big crocodile in
there you will be okay I suppose I can
hardly judge it for being slightly
traumatized
yes it's crossing everyone look at this
it's gone into the water is is going to
go across to the other side will it
survive the gauntlet I'm sorry I mean
the puddle I think it's okay I think it
lived quite pretty when you look at them
I wanted to find you a male because the
big males when they start running around
chasing other males is also hilarious
and then I get distracted by a female
that apparently smells more attractive
than the rest and then they desperately
try and leap onto her back her
unsuspecting back and she just kind of
walks away from them quite hilarious
yeah what's going on there there might
be the world's greatest gifted
mathematicians we'd never know but this
is just the start we're going to go to
the Salt Lick the great watering hole of
the Maasai Mara meanwhile Sydney is at
the great watering hole of Juma I'm just
trying to check if I can find a very
nice place to dig a little bit so that I
can show you something very much
interesting so I'm just looking for the
roots of this grass the name of this
grass is called the coach grass so the
coach grass their root system is very
much interesting and this is one of the
very medicinal plants I know a lot of
people they only think about the big
trees as a source of medicine now I've
got something different if you look at
these graphs you can see that just got
like a rhizome so this rhizome is where
this grass is touring the food for
survival so if you can take these
rhizomes with these roots and boil them
drink that water is going to help you in
order to clean the urinary system this
kind of a grass
while I was still very young we used to
go out to the field for ploughing
purposes and sometimes when the mouse is
dry we used to dig and take this kind of
sticks and chew them they are very much
City and shew them and by so doing this
and then it does moisturize the inner
part of the mouth so it is a very
interesting grass and is a very
medicinal grass it's not sour at all
it's very much nice and a lot of animals
like the Rhinos white rhinos
specifically they prefer to eat a lot of
Coach grass that is why if you've got
Coach grass in the reserve where is
occuring you will see the area will be
having shorter grass
as animals a lot of them they like to
feed on this kind of grasses so here I
have seen that this grass is very much
excited is growing very high because
it's close to the water holes and his
kind of roots can be able to easily
absorb water to here from that close
water hole so now I'm going to carry on
and see if we can find something very
much interesting on this guide at work I
am expecting to see a lot of tiny little
animals what I'm going to look for this
animals let's see
James is lucky with Tenggara at the
moment yes
Kangana you can see is not moved but
he's not reclining like his son is and
that is because he is deeply afraid that
his sunday roast is under threat my
father's quite the same actually you
know I imagining one last piece of roast
chicken me arriving uninvited at the
house and going to the fridge and trying
to take the last drumstick I imagine my
father might behave in much the same way
that Tenggara is behaving towards horse
Anna I don't think that he would stay
awake for nearly as long there I think
he'd fall asleep quite quickly then I
would have the chicken leg afternoon rx2
Leopard still static same place I
haven't gone anywhere else I'm just
giving Ric's on an update on the radio
they're both are on the ground I'm just
telling what they're doing now obviously
he said what are they doing are they up
or down
Safari go yes there certainly would
challenge a leopard if a wild dog came
along here both these slippers to be up
into a tree very quickly while dogs not
nice to lipids lipids being solitary
well supposedly solitary are unwilling
to take the risks to fight off a
predator like wild dogs and so you would
find that they would seek the safety of
the branches where wild dogs couldn't
get at them wild dogs a lot braver
because they're in packs and they'd go
for these lepers if they came along here
wouldn't just come past see then
Lipper's and then leave them be all
right how about we go and see about
those dogs should we go and do that I
think we should I will come back here a
little bit later but I feel that it
would be remissive of us not to go and
see if we can find the wild dogs and
then perhaps the Lions even a little bit
later but I'm not sure about those well
Simon did to just lift his head
but that's watching Garner's eyes are
open we can't see him though they don't
share because it's just not what animals
do out here some do wild dogs share and
we're going to see if we can find them
now but cats just don't share with each
other you know not even the Lions will
share with each other they fight with
each other over food and it's because
they didn't they are they are solitary
creatures which means they prefer to be
on their own when they're adults and
that means that they will defend their
food it means that they will take every
opportunity they can to eat because they
don't know when they will next eat and
so they will always try and protect
their food from other leopards or hyenas
or anything else that might try and
steal their food there is young hasana
you can see him fast asleep but every
time he lifts his head ting ganas eyes
flick open
there he is
this is very special for those of you
who are perhaps new viewers I mean we're
sitting here with two male leopards on a
Sunday afternoon this is not something
that happens every Sunday afternoon will
indeed any other afternoon but we have a
unique situation here at Juma because
husana the male liver does not quite yet
gone independent to what he certainly
independent but he hasn't quite old
enough yet to take a territory of his
own and so he's still living within his
father's ambit he's like a maturing
adolescent or young human being male
who's living in the garden cottage but
still coming into the house every so
often to ferret around in the bread bin
and I suppose ting ganas perspective if
we were to anthropomorphize it further
would be this is my house and you've
done nothing to earn yourself a place in
a house like this you know you don't
defend territory you don't fight off
rival males you just mooch around here
eating the prey within my territory so
this is your form of rent old buddy old
pal I'll tolerate you here but make
their mistake that defer this food to
going I'm gonna have it first
and he certainly wouldn't be lying here
calm and collected if or thana wasn't
related to him I think he'd be much more
it isn't about being tolerant of him and
try and chase him off and likewise
wasana wouldn't I don't think try and
spend time around a male leopard that he
didn't know well it still windy here a
little bit like it is in the Masai Mara
and out it's blowing quite that hard but
the northwest wind of August still
continues to blow and we're not really
getting into the meaty part of the fire
season it will culminate or climax with
the first storms that come through this
area lightning strikes that set the
tinderbox of this grassland or the
woodland area to flame and you found
that with one of these hot northwest
winds and you can have something quite
spectacular and a little bit dangerous
of course spectacular as it may be it's
always a little bit dangerous watch
young can go on a fast asleep there so
let's go back to the watch as now in the
Masai Mara we're gonna go out and see if
we can't find the wild dogs well you
take to the skies above the Mara with
some scavengers lots of vultures and
it's really quite lovely because up
until the arrival of my at the migration
I was barely seeing if I was seeing 1
vulture a week it was a lot and I found
that I actually really missed them a
funny colour in the Sun then we've got
rupal x' and white backed vultures and i
for one am very very happy to see them
the vulture numbers have taken an
enormous knock and throughout this
ecosystem as a result of poisoned
carcasses which is deeply tragic and
essentially a carcass gets laced with
poison and laid out sometimes aiming for
the vultures mostly aiming for other
predators and scavengers
and getting the Volscians as a side
effect but they've come back with with a
vengeance with the arrival of the
migration and most of them will follow
the herd as it goes through its yearly
rotation now they're here now because
the wildebeest are here now and there
will be carcasses strewn everywhere
throughout the Mara triangle Oh Kathy I
don't know if I could exactly just
define the migrations purpose
essentially it is to ensure that there
is enough food for large numbers of
animals and it just so happens that in
this ecosystem in this bit in this
particular way that Nature has set
things up food is better here in the
Maasai Mara at this time of year and
then for four months of all the beasts
and the zebra as well because it does
include a couple of hundred thousand
zebra they will then move back to
Tanzania where the food is good they'll
give in the case of the wildebeest they
will give birth there it's essentially a
massive circle but to call it a circle
would be to to really oversimplify it
the herd split up they move in different
directions but essentially they are
doing a rotation around usually led by
the zebra they're usually the first to
arrive they can utilize the longer
stalks of the grass you guys having a
good scratch there what is the purpose
of a migration essentially it just means
that animals have found a way or Nature
has found a way to make sure that
animals utilize resources in a
sustainable way if a million wildebeest
were to gather and graze for twelve
months of the year in the same place
there would be a disaster because there
would be no more grass left now as the
rains roll through we are actually just
coming out of the driest period in the
Maasai Mara
and Jared's buddy there is of course
always a section of the population and I
think it's around about 50,000 or so it
might be a little bit more than that it
could even be a hundred thousand I'm not
sure of the exact number and I'll tell
you why I'm not sure in a second there
there's a section of the vote of the
wildebeest that don't migrate there are
some that actually stay local completely
but that's one or two individuals every
couple of thousand hectares that stick
around then there is the loiter herd
which goes up into the LOI to herd into
the loiter Hills in Kenya at LOI ta to
avoid confusion and they that migration
route is starting to find serious
interference because of fences so
there's fences going up along their
natural migration route there's no
fences between us and the Serengeti but
there there is between where the loiters
want to be and so as a result the
migrations not quite getting the same
numbers that it should be that is of
course how South Africa managed to do
away with the migration almost as large
as this one large actually than this one
a massive migration of antelope that's
used to occur in South Africa that no
longer does I was just saying to Archie
it's my it's a great sadness that I know
that there is no road to get us
underneath that sausage tree I really
would love to go there I know the lions
love it there I can see all the vultures
sitting up there doesn't necessarily
mean that there's lions underneath it
there are so many carcasses everywhere
that the vultures are just everywhere
you can't use them at this time of year
to find well you can you can you can use
them when they're landing but you can't
on the ground you can't really use them
when they're sitting in a tree to find
the cats and just by the way I don't
think that tree is dead
I think the first half of it or the
right-hand side of its just losing its
leaves in preparation of new ones okay
now no matter how many animals make
their way all the way from Tanzania to
the Mara it will still pale in
comparison to the number of termites in
just one colony
a lot of people don't realize that when
working out here on the ground we are
walking right on top of the roof of
quite a lot of animals staying under the
ground and some of these animals are the
Mongoose here I have got a very
convincing evidence that the Mongoose
are staying under the ground in this
termite mound so these animals that are
staying under the ground they are called
for soria and these animals by staying
under the ground they help themselves
when it comes to animals such as
predators because they can easily hide
away and the story doesn't end there
apart from avoiding the predation
activities they also help themselves
when it comes to the high temperatures
such as hot temperatures and when it's
cold as well so you can see that staying
under the ground is very much beneficial
to these animals so the animals that are
staying on the ground they experience
quite a lot of predation activities so
here a colony of the a colony of of
these Mongoose is staying in here
probably this is the - of Mongoose so
the termite mound is becoming a host
because in the the temperature is
excellent and that is what is attracting
these small animals and I'm sure they
are very much safe maybe the problem is
if the snakes goes in there but the
Mongoose don't have that big problems
with the snakes because they can kill
them so they are very much Gregorius
they are not solitary and for them to
win a fight against the snakes
the chances are always very there so
they are very much shy they might be
hiding under this
the termites they are not harmful to the
other animals termites can be harmful to
the animals that predates them and the
most predator of the termites is the
artifact the artifact can be able to
come here and dig fast as 15 minutes is
6 meters hold down and it can consume up
to 400,000 to 500,000 a half a million
termites at the same time yes they do
have some of the Predators which are
more or less the same as their body size
the ants also predate the termites and
when ants are coming in is well they
defend themselves they fight against the
ants but when it comes the artifacts is
a big animal which makes it very
difficult for this kind of small insects
to protect themselves against now let's
go to a jetty she does have a small
lizard interesting to see a lizard I
haven't seen any at the moment we're
sorry to drag you away from all the
action but we've got you something
really pretty to look at and I was so
worried that it was going to dash away
although I have to say it's been very
very relaxed a rock a gamma a beautiful
beautiful member of the lizard family
who is currently making use of the late
afternoon Sun before the evening chill
sets in I once heard David Guiteau Gigi
wonderful Kenyan guide call them
spider-man lizards because of course
they've got the Spider Man coloring now
there was a second one there is she gone
she's gone into hiding she's obviously
more shy oh no there we go I'm saying
she that's not an absolute so gamez it's
the usually the big males that have that
bright coloring in the females that
the dole coloring however sometimes you
get mails that actually almost imitate
the females and they as a result get
away with hanging out in a more dominant
lizards territory and sneaking in
quickly when he's not looking and
grabbing hold of the female so it could
be a male or a female
but I'm guessing most likely it's a
female what's fascinating me at the
moment is that opening behind their eyes
it's enormous and protected by very
clear scales now I assume and I should
know this I assume it had something to
do with hearing anyway it doesn't matter
right now let's go and see what James
has found for you well it's difficult
not to have found them they were
standing right in the road for us we've
kind of blocked the road which I didn't
mean to do but now they've kind of
wandered around us and they're close by
so I don't want to start the engine the
big mate shock I think that's the big
mate show up to our left she's kind of
given us the BD I decided she can get
around us without tipping us over on
turfing us onto the ground so we're just
gonna sit here very quietly they're very
close and you are 2 meters away and
they're so close I can smell them there
was such a lovely comforting smell to me
the best thing I can liken it to or the
most obvious thing I can liken it to i
supposes horses they smell a little bit
like horses do and then I always found
that a comforting smell as a kid
there's a little one coming towards us
now going to show us how very strong he
is in your host one oh yes what test one
fellow with a long nose but a bit
nervous nice to be next to Mum they are
massive everybody it's difficult to
conceive of how big they are until you
are sitting this close to them it really
is quite phenomenal how vast they are
she stands at around 10 feet at the
shoulder it's pretty big you know watch
her her friend has blocked the way now
where she could get on the back I
suppose she was now moving a fairly
substantial knob thorn with her foot
it was unbelievable how strong they are
they're not particularly strong as far
as animals go with regard to their
power-to-weight ratio so they couldn't
do many pull-ups for example but they
are obviously by virtue of their sides
and in absolute terms enormously strong
there's one there with that very long
tusks and I think we know her I think
she should probably be called toothpick
or spear one other two one long tusks
and one both the north tusks
Amanda the one on the left pregnant um I
can't see any that are pregnant at the
moment
well not none that are obviously
pregnant that her about to pop it's only
really then that you can tell if an
elephant's pregnant she might be
actually this one here folks the one in
front of us
she has got a swelling up to the side of
her belly we go to her for this one here
yeah she has got a little bit of a
swelling there but I know I'm not
convinced about that all some discipline
being meted out by toothpick to a
youngster obviously got a little bit
testy in the heat now this herd has just
been at Buffalo Dan having a bit of a
mud bath I suspect I'm not sure how much
drinking they did there even the fowls
of the water they certainly would have
had a nice mud bath there's tooth
toothpick is now breaking a leaf in
front of us I see it it's difficult for
you to see her properly
nice Paul I think toothpicks quad nice
name as well now here comes a bull down
the road in front of us he's not
particularly old he is however in the
process of testing that female for her
readiness to mate that is what he's
doing there I'd put him at about thirty
years old
look at him approaching the female look
how much bigger he is than her I mean
he's a monstrous size I always think the
females are he enormous until I see a
big bull like this can you see his hip
sticking out there I think he's had a
bit of a rough winter it doesn't have to
be in the best condition on his hip
sticking out like that I don't think
he's in must he's certainly not dripping
at all from between his legs there's
none of that evil smelling green penis
syndromes what they call it where there
leak huge amounts of water and he's also
got a very rounded forint it's quite
nice we often talk about the Bulls as
having rounded foreheads compared to the
cows and there's a nice example of that
now I wouldn't be too worried if this
fellow
turned to us and shook his head I don't
think he's old enough to give us too
much trouble there's a little bit of
debate about elephants eyesight I don't
think it's as bad as a lot of people say
it is I don't think it's fantastic I've
you know I'm just trying to think when
you're on foot it's obviously difficult
to tell whether they've seen or smelled
you and this you are downwind of them
and then they do pick you up if you
stand out in the open they'll pick you
up but if you stand quietly in thick
bush they often don't see you they also
apparently have a blind spot pretty much
where we're sitting in relation to this
bull here and if you were to approach
from where we are now on foot and didn't
make a noise
he apparently and I mean I've yet to try
this myself would not see obviously he
uses more than just his his eyes to
sense things and since potential danger
this is quite cute a little baby with
the ball oh this is very sweet see I
tried to just touch the mail I doubt
it's related to him a cool I would
imagine that he'd be too young to be
that elephant's father but it's possible
and now another big strong one same
biggest one one that showed us how
strong it was a little earlier
yes feeling very confident in the front
of the big ball when he knows we'll
probably protect him should any trouble
occur
so he I would say he probably weighs in
at around four and a half to five tonnes
and Paula that little chap there would
only weigh about probably between 150
and 200 kilograms or so which is about
440 pounds then they're born they're
weigh 220 pounds I mean that is
dreadfully cute isn't it now the big
bull giving him a bit of a smack just
saying go away I don't wish to be around
you
he just gave a little bit of us wasn't a
snort it was definitely fun the voice
box that sort of low Rumble that they
made make even more and the little one
cleared off totally unconcerned by us at
this stage not vaguely interested or
worried about us which is fantastic it's
ideally best when a four and a half to
five ton animal isn't worried about your
prisons I find that generally to be the
most acceptable situation
- yeah know what you mean you can't stop
smiling at this sighting I feel quite
similar actually it's just almost not
almost it is it's a tremendous privilege
to spend this kind of time with
elephants with any animal really in this
close proximity with any wild animal
that has taken you into its confidence
almost and said it's alright I don't
mind if you're around don't create it
too much of a ruckus but you can watch
us feeding I don't think that's
necessarily a conscious decision this
big bulls from taken but he's certainly
not affected enough by us to let us
worry him which is fantastic does very
much feel like being taken into the
confidence of an wild animal I'm not
gonna move from here I'm gonna see and
wait until these elephants move away
when Jaime Patterson is still sitting
with her wanzer I'm very excited to hear
what she has to say about him one's
awesome absolutely sightings I also
really enjoy the opportunity for a
close-up lizard sighting so we haven't
moved because their garments haven't
moved so it's a chance for us just to
sit and appreciate them in all of their
scaly glory very very rough scaled
lizards sharp claws for gripping onto
rocks and leaping after their insect
prey and this will be believe it or not
this will also be a time of Plenty for
them because the number of wildebeest
alive or dead will bring forth a great
number of flies and I thought he was
that sitting there for a second as if to
say I really tell me more
changed his head position now but for
them it will be a time of Plenty as well
lots and lots of flies which means lots
and lots of food I was still staring at
that opening I assume it's a sort of it
you know it's a it's an opening for an
ear and we're a simplified ear with a
sort of tympanic membrane system I don't
actually know and I want to know if it's
got some degree of control over it and
I've never had a pet lizard with this or
of this sort of kind of Nevada pet
lizard . i wonder if any of you out
there have a gamez or have knowledge of
exactly how that works can they control
it can they open and close it i've not
100% sure and i'm curious as to whether
or not they can i assume they can it
looks like it why is so wide open when
it's sitting in the sun this thing may
be a Don I'm actually not 100% sure but
I find it fascinating looks like such a
vulnerable unprotected spot
pfff lizards are ectotherms in other
words that they rely on the outside
temperature in order to control or
regulate their body temperature there
are some lizards that have more control
over their internal body temperatures or
at least are more functional at colder
temperatures than others
hey now you decide you've gone okay that
have more control a gecko would be a
good example of one such lizard that can
actually operate at lower temperatures
but it's so if they're cold they go into
the Sun when we go into a warm pilot
spot if they get too hot they'll go into
a shady spot but their energy levels
will largely depend on their temperature
so if they're really cold they're really
really lethargic and they actually can't
move all that fast that's why and not to
name anything specific that's why
certain documentaries where they go
running out and leap out and catch a
snake that's you know seems relatively
docile and they they show off their
snake handling skills a lot of those
times those snakes have actually been
put in cooler boxes first cooled down to
the point that they do not have the
energy to fight back to move around or
to move away which is a horrifying
thought I'm not saying any particular
type of documentary but that is
occasionally the case horrible thought
that's why people who keep pet reptiles
of course will have little lamps and
help to keep them warm and help them to
regulate their temperature crocodiles
have quite a strong degree of control
over their internal body temperature
without having to rely too much on the
outside world but they'll still go in
bask just as these lizards are doing
it's been fun sitting with these agamas
but now it's time to send you back on
over to Sydney who back from leave is
full of stories to tell you in things to
show you I have got one of the very very
much interesting plant here this is a
barb it's very much difficult to
identify it but this bulb from how it
looks I know what it does this is one of
those bulbs people can use as an
anti-venom and as an anti snakes and
this snakes I'm referring to I'm
referring to an act whereby when you
come across the snakes the snakes just
got to coil themselves they cannot raise
their head against you at all so what we
do is that we come and we take these
kind of skin all these skins and we also
take some other piece it's like a big
onion under the ground and we take that
part and we've got to inject it in your
body and it's going to stay there and it
will be there permanently meaning that
every time the snake picks your scent it
is going to know that this is the wrong
person I cannot free fight against this
person a calf is iam and then just got
to coil itself and then you can be able
to just take it from the house and
release it so that it can go away so we
don't really kill all snakes where I
come from we catch them and then lease
them for them to go when having problems
if you put a wound as well you come and
take these skills you can use them you
can stitch them against the wound then
it can serve as an antibiotic so this
tree is very much interesting to see
that now is now blooming so this tells
us that the trees are now starting to
get excited towards the spring I am sure
this tree is having a mechanism in order
to regulate the predation activities
because here where I am this is the only
plant which is having the leaves which
means
this is gonna attract some of the
animals to come here so I'm sure this
plant is having a high level of tannin
in order to avoid animals from coming to
feed on eight other victories are still
waiting not yet convinced with a weather
condition towards the spring interesting
to see that the vegetation doesn't wait
for any kind of an announcement to say
now is spraying less bloom they know
themselves that is the right time
through a natural process very much
interesting Ryan thank you very much for
the comment indeed it is a very powerful
plant it's one of those plants as well
people are using in order to fight
against the evil spirit where I come
from if you buy a stand if is it a new
it is a new stand even if it's an old
stand you're gonna have to then call a
traditional healer to come and do
something at that stand and what they
normally do the traditional healers they
go and dig this kind of plant and they
come and plant them in your yard when
that plant is there it is going to help
you against the evil spirit so now I
hear James has got some elephants let's
see how the elephants are doing this
afternoon I miss the elephant
we haven't left the elephants they big
bull has not moved at all tooth Pickers
standing next to him in war in front of
him and then a youngster is sort of
smelling the older boy to see if he's
friendly or not he is studiously
ignoring the young bull who wants to be
his friend
they can we'll just chased away a
hornbill some sort of deferred
aggression
perhaps irritated that the old boy
didn't want to be his friend
there is the handle sorry old fellow
Jayden sucks being that small doesn't it
and there you feel you can probably hear
the breaking of the branches all around
us no Tony that is a legend I think
associated with rhino rather than
elephants isn't it that they will stomp
out fires I've never seen them stomp out
fires I've been around elephants and
fires no I think it's completely a
legend now look how this bull is trying
to get at the bark of this tree he's
eaten the small twigs
now he's flirting but he's also he's
also trying to get at the bark of the
tree and you can see they're little
places where it's been stripped off so
you'll eat all of the little twigs and
then try and strip the brach off and you
know that tree must be sitting there in
abject terror focus is an elephant about
to take a lil back hello my dear she's
the mother of the very brave one that
was attacking us earlier there he is
I don't want to start the car obviously
so you're just gonna deal with the
aerial in the frame of the car and
afraid starting it will break the spell
at this magic sighting no she's trying
to suckle and probably going to start
whining quite soon and this is loud too
Circle so I was saying about this tree I
think it's probably sitting here in
abject terror because it's being picked
off piece by piece but eventually one of
them's just gonna push it over our
suspect
yeah I think it probably was project
alpha that Ryanair thing about was
probably from the gods must be crazy
which is a fun film made in the 80s I
think it was the 80s early eighties
about the San Bushmen and yeah
rhinos stamping out fires baboons and
monkeys getting drunk on the ruler
fruits and that sort of thing called
absolute nonsense and in fact those
baboons and monkeys as far as I remember
when I heard sort of about the behinds
of the scenes of that particular film
now I think those baboons and monkeys
were drugged and that's why they looked
as though they were drunk I suspect that
they probably infused the infused the
fruits of vodka or something like that
yeah which is horrible it's really not
nice there's beautiful people are funny
people that's right Fergus is just
saying there's another similar kind of a
film where they did that it may have not
been the gods must be crazy than at all
Amanda I don't know as far as I'm aware
all mammals just about scootering can
get rabies I know with the exception of
hyenas and Mongoose which can carry but
don't express rabies so they all carry
it but they say if you get bitten by a a
mongoose or a hyena that has rabies you
will get it but it's not necessarily
true that it will in fact the animals
that have bitten you will not I think
some monkey species also can carry it
and not express it but as far as I'm
aware most mammals can get rabies I
don't know how a elephant would get
rabies and be terrifying to see but I'm
gonna say on the balance of what I know
about rabies yes they probably can
have they ever I don't know imagine
having a herd of rabid elephants around
the place obviously the disease would
kill them very quickly but it would be
fairly terrifying until it did yes I'm
not sure ought to be a good movie
Kirsten Kirsten says would be a good
movie it would certainly be a movie that
would sell along with exactly what I was
going to say a little bit like sharknado
and snakes on a plane now if you haven't
ever seen sharknado do yourself a favor
and don't unless you have had too much
to drink and have perhaps taken some
form of a narcotic because then you'll
find it very amazing it is the principle
of the film is that basically what
happens is tornados rush over the sea
and in so doing pick up sharks who are
kept alive somehow within the sharknado
and then dumped into cities yes I know
it's isn't that ridiculous it sounds
like something you'd dream about and I
have actually not seen it I've seen bits
of it they made a four or five of them
we have a sort of low-budget movie
channel in this country that a sharknado
appears on disturbingly frequently it's
not good focus it's dreadful it is yes
jagged yes elephants on a plane not
quite as terrifying as snakes on a plane
if you haven't seen snakes on a plane
again possibly best to do so at the back
end of a big night or some narcotics
because some of the scenes in that are a
ridiculous but to the point of being
hilarious
it's a it is a not quite x-rated but
it's certainly a highly age restricted
film
I wouldn't recommend watching it but if
you do well I suppose you might find it
quite funny don't take it seriously
there please
snakes on the plane water water
principle ah I haven't seen that one d
hugs Lake Placid well have I oh no about
huge crocodiles I haven't seen that one
I haven't seen Lake Placid either a
sharknado takes the cake you can see
this elephant is not vaguely concerned
the shock made in fact I suspect he's
probably never seen it
now Jamie he must understand he's asking
what about anaconda the Jaime has
obviously not seen sharknado because if
she had she would know that it was in a
different class it is in a class all of
its own
in fact and the Condren snakes on a
plane I suppose you might put in the
same class but sharknado is in a new
class of its own its level of
ridiculousness is so bizarre and Jamie
says I am correct she has not seemed
sharknado shock film filmed in Port
Alfred Fergus is just saying there's
been a shock film filmed in Port Alfred
which is quite near where my parents
live that's where Ralph Liz
wandering bard unless you can show me
some sort of hard evidence I'm going to
disbelieve what you've just said now you
said you heard that sharknado was based
on some kind of real story
I am afraid I'm unable to believe that
shocks have ever been sucked out of the
water in numbers and dumped on the land
by ocean-going tornados you gonna have
to show me some kind of documentary
peer-reviewed evidence before I'll
believe anything like that as far as I'm
aware tornado can't exist over water can
it a sharknado certainly generated
enough interest for them to make for
movies thank you for putting this up you
say there have been six sharknado movies
not just full Thank You James Richard
not even this elephant is outraged you
can see stuck his ears up and absolute
disgust look at him he says if you're
going to stand here and talk such utter
garbage while I am magnificently
displaying myself in front of you well
then I tell you what I'm going to
threaten you slightly
he's standing on his heel there he's
thinking about coming towards us no he's
going to walk around the back of the
street Ryan I think it's an excellent
idea I think rabid elephants on a plane
would be a fantastic film and there goes
our bull that is the end of our elephant
sighting as we consider rabid elephants
on a plane a movie directed by I don't
think we'll find a director to direct
that fluence Ryan you might have to
offer to direct it yourself James may
know I don't know James Bay right Fergus
and I will try and find a director for
this wonderful film rabid elephants on
the plane while you go across to Jamie
who will give you something intelligent
to say I reckon
now I could tell James exactly who needs
to direct that movie I can give him a
director his director of photography and
his scriptwriter and that is our very
own vim or the Valle de beast as he has
known a one of our cameraman are
extraordinary cameraman with a true
sense for the bizarre are we spend
extended periods of time out in the Mara
and often several days in a robe with
the same cameraman and you have to find
things to keep yourself occupied because
after a while I spy with my little eye
grass loses its appeal Servian beams
distraction is to come up with different
combinations of animals like a Lila
crested hyena
and of course now that I'm thinking
about it I can't remember one of them
the leopard faced vulture not leopard
leopard faced vulture and and so on so
if James needs a director for his movie
or at the very least a scriptwriter I
think he need look no further I will of
course I will of course naturally have
to go immediately and watch sharknado
and given that it comes as a
recommendation from someone whose
opinion I hold an extraordinarily high
regard and I say that without any
sarcasm at all this is true even that
sounded sarcastic I'm really not being
sarcastic
as it comes from someone whose opinion I
hold in such high regard I will of
course expect it to be everything that I
have been led to believe and I will in
no way and accept that it is it is not a
good movie big thing you know he gets
sued for something I don't know
promoting something over something else
I feel like there's going to be a lot
more hits on sharknado after the end of
the sunset Safari nothing at the Salt
Lick by the way on to more pressing
matters there's not a single bull the
Beast
I'm deeply take advice cries and I could
only assume it's because a large animal
equivalent to the Lake Placid crocodile
has taken residence there and scared
everything off we'll have to make a
movie about that I'm too scared to go
close though because that's the funk
everyone knows the film crew is always
the first to go we can't have that being
by the way to continue a somewhat
labored subjects VM has an entire plot
line for a horror movie set in the Masai
Mara and I cannot tell you what it is
because he would be very deeply hurt if
someone were to steal his idea based on
the fact that I shared it but we have
brainstorms
the time the researchers went too far
it's basically deep blue sea we've seen
deep blue sea there's one that James
forgot
it's basically deep blue sea but with a
different animal that's all I can tell
you
bizarre conversations that we have
I think if you if you could hear us some
of the time you would really seriously
question our sanity I actually have got
a destination in mind by the way it's
just up ahead we have a gathering what
Archie described as a as a business
meeting and that's exactly what it looks
like a business meeting of feathered
scavengers gathered together around the
bulbous shaped conference table but far
away but it'll do so she's so nice that
my brakes don't squeak anymore people
used to be here me hear me coming about
20 kilometers away now Aaron while we
watch our vultures pick away as some
unfortunate wildebeest and on a slightly
more serious unless a satirical b-grade
note
I don't think than the Parmalat sorry I
laugh every time I say the Parmalat
vulture because it's called a palm not
vulture that's not what I'm trying to
say that the joke about Parmalat came
from our trip to Uganda last year with
Rebecca and Craig and Brent and I were
incredibly excited to see a palm not a
vulture but they assumed that we were
calling it a Parmalat vulture now
Parmalat is a type it's a brand in South
Africa so know as far as I know the palm
nut vulture which is that was very
unintentional has not been seen I'm sure
it's around though I mean there are so
many vultures right now it's entirely
possible look it's right on the fringes
you don't they don't occur regularly in
the Mara but it is something that we
could see and have seen but no I haven't
seen the part a lot vulture there we go
is the chairman the marabou stork the
CEO Oh watch out watch it gentlemen
please
this is a professional environment the
ripples vulture chasing away the white
pact they're just slightly bigger than
the white pact voltar's so they have a
little bit of a an advantage and of the
way they run after each other the
marabou looks like an inspector now
coming to check out their work see if
there's anything he can grab yep there
we go I'll take that thank you while you
gentlemen are otherwise occupied thank
you very much now let's wildebeest
probably it's hard to tell exactly why
it died might have been injured in a
crossing and only recently have the
injuries fully taken effect it could
have had a broken leg that got infected
it could have been caught by a lion
lions often abandon their kills during a
migration period they don't bother to
eat them so it could have been that I
don't think it was a hyena kill because
hyenas generally speaking don't leave
anything left behind for this other
scavengers they will eat and eat and eat
and eat and eat until it's all gone is
that just the vultures chilling out or
yeah I think they've eaten niffle' so it
could be the the potential reasons for
demise could be endless Margherita was
that a deliberate pun you know is there
a pecking order when it comes to
vultures
I liked it if it was probably whether
she probably exactly where the phrase
pecking order came from come to think of
it it's a bit embarrassing I never
thought of that
yes there is a pecking order when it
comes to the feeding hierarchy at a
carcass the biggest vulture out here and
one I tried to put on camera earlier but
it flew away is called a lappet-faced
vulture not to be confused with the
leopard faced vulture which is not real
and been made up
now the lappet-faced vulture is massive
with an enormous leap our fulfil
unfortunately there aren't any here that
is then followed by the rupaul's
vultures and the white back vultures
with the marabou stork falling somewhere
in that selection but mara boos aren't
as
bulky as a vulture so they're actually
even though they are bigger and they
were very powerful bulls they often get
pushed around that kills like this
especially if they're outnumbered and
then last a button definitely not least
comes the little oh my goodness its
names just gone out of my head
toothpick vultures small heads tiny
balls somebody help me please I'm having
a complete brain blank what are they
called
hooded how did I get there eventually my
goodness I don't know what that was
hooded vulture
good grief there little hooded vultures
that will come along and pick up the
scraps and get to the bits of meat that
the other vultures with their large
beaks cannot get to so that's by and
large Margherita is the pecking order of
vultures and it is literally enforced
you guessed it by pecking I've been off
for two drives I don't know what I'm
talking about anymore
Katie who is one of our 15 year old
viewers it's wonderful to hear from you
Katie wants to know what the vultures
like the best all animals if all meat
eaters or parn avoids if faced with an
animal carcass the best part for them is
the organs the internal organs that's
where the most nutrients are liver heart
kidneys lungs those sorts of things
that's richest in iron blood vessels
it's just it's just the best part of the
meal for them now for smaller species of
vulture and actually in any situation
where the animal hasn't been killed by a
lion or a leopard and birds have
actually moved in the first thing to go
is the eyes sounds grisly sounds
gruesome it is a little gresling
gruesome but it's just how it goes
that's the easiest part for them to get
to so while it might not be the most
rewarding part in that is there's
nutrients but not a vast amount of
nutrients from the eye it is the easiest
it requires the least effort so the eyes
are the first to go and then if they can
something like a lappet-faced vulture
will then move in and open up the
abdomen if there's an injury if the
animals died of an injury that becomes a
little bit easier but it is still
something that they have to work out
animal skin is frightening eat up
and again their bowls are suited to
different things so hooded vulture can't
go up to a carcass and tear off a big
chunk of flesh its beak is just not big
enough it doesn't have enough strength
whereas something like a RuPaul's or a
lappet-faced can actually come and take
full advantage of those strips of muscle
so it will also depend upon the vulture
itself I'm just a boot I know I've moved
on but it's because I'd like to get to
I'd like to get to Awful's before the
end of the drive just so I can see if
those Cubs are still alive and well I've
spoken to the researchers this morning
and they say that polar bears cub so for
those of you that have kept up you'll
know what I mean for those of you that
haven't don't stress it's another female
hyena she's also got a small cub and
they said it was off today and suckling
so it's okay but there was no sign of
waffles so I just want to go and see
that she's all right so that her cubs
are okay at some point I will have to
sever the ties with North clan
I will but I'm not quite there yet you
know I have to go see if they're okay
after the rains okay let's go back to a
walk with Sydney through the bush I'm
trying to get hold of some of the very
interesting medicinal plants and some of
the small animals and here in front of
me I have got one of the interesting
plant this is what is called a nuclear
divine aura this kind of a plant if
you've got it at home it is going to
bring you good luck that is one of the
beliefs associated with quite a lot of
African tribes it's one of the evergreen
plants and I'm just not too sure what is
it that this tree is using in order to
repel animals from coming to feed on it
I know the evergreen plants they have
got a very strong kind of a plastic coat
here on top which then repelled animals
from eating on them during the dry
season but let me also get the taste it
does taste very bad maybe is one of the
reasons why these animals are not coming
here because it's very much beta maybe
this is due to fight a whole lot of
training on them but something
interesting about training is that we as
human beings we need 10 in animals when
the turning voltage is high where they
are feeding it is going to constipate
and they experience the digestive
problem but us we need turning in order
to trouble some or to troubleshoot some
of the diseases diseases such as the
diabetes diabetes is one of the diseases
which is caused by the problems when it
comes to the processing of sugar in the
body when they eat those kind of
problems we need to eat the trees that
are rich if the leaves from the trees
that are rich in turning so that we can
troubleshoot those kind of a problem I
got a request earlier
that some of you my viewers are
interested to hear more about the other
applications we are using when it comes
to the medicinal uses against the snakes
I think it is a request from Safari
Sally yes
Safari sorry we do have other kind of
plans we are using in order to treat the
snakebite and some of them they are
carrying here in Juma game reserve I
always find it very much interesting to
talk about h3 that you are seeing
meaning that this kind of request I am
going to put it on hold soon as I come
across one of the trees that we are
using ss snake bites treatment I'm gonna
carry on and give you more information
and how we apply it Kathy your question
about the reason why the you clear
divine aura is bringing good luck is
that you cleared evanora
is a magical plant that is why is called
a magic väri
and if you can check its scientific name
it is called a nuclear divine aura and
that divine aura has got something to do
with the traditional healers east lock
is a magic tree is very very much
important to have this tree in the yard
here in Africa
I'm just gonna try more and see if I can
find other interesting things that I can
share with you here battling too much to
find they to find the small things but
now let's go to James James one of my
colleagues maybe at the moment he does
have something interesting
no I don't write I've come to where they
last had the wild dogs but the wild dogs
appeared to have absconded and I suspect
what they've done is gone to find
themselves some shade in a different
place from where they were this morning
which is making me so in my heart
because I was planning on having a drive
where I really didn't have to look very
hard for anything leopards were a good
start
elephants an excellent placeholder and
now I was hoping to just bumble into the
wild hounds this has not happened
unfortunately and because we're on a
major northern boundary the chances of
finding the treks of slim because people
drive up and down this road is a great
speed and frequency anyway
we might be lucky
we'll drive very slowly if we go and
pick up some tracks
there's another little road we can go
down and check which will do it'd be
nice to get them they are of course my
favorite mammal out here and it is
national dog day in the United States
imagine not showing you some dogs for
national dog day didn't travesty awful
traffic travel to sheriff travesty I
think it would be doubly unjust of me
since I wasted your time talking about
sharknado tracks
poor people yes wild dogs are often on
the move they are on the move
crepuscular Li Li Li Li Li so just
before and after dawn and just after
dawn and dusk it doesn't make any sense
did it as I was trying to concentrate on
one thing I'm not sure that there's
anything fresh here food but thank you
so they're active ok Pascal early before
dawn and after dawn and just before dusk
and start to dusk they will move pretty
much in the darkness from time to time
but they'll get moving
sort of I suppose in about half an hour
I'd expect them to get moving here
and then they could easily head north or
south down to alt quarantine clearings
of the go south and up towards one of
the water holes and biffle's hook if
they go north that poofy poof is how
they move
exceptional name I must keep
complimenting you on your Twitter handle
poufy poof and been some very good ones
over the years
okay I'm not sure that you could
describe it is stable no I think my last
check there were probably 300 to 350
wild dogs in the Kruger National Park
you know that'll vary quite a lot it's
probably relatively stable but I don't
think it's it's certainly not as high as
it once was and I suspect it could be
higher and I think the major problem is
that it keeps coming into contact with
domestic animals outside the fence and
it's a real disaster for wild dogs just
there's a little road down here which
we'll go and check see if the carton
finds any tracks or signs and lock time
I'm not sure what time the last person
to be with them left you know if they
had just fed and they were just lying
down well then they may not have moved
no Lindsay that's not possible wild dogs
and domestic dogs cannot interbreed
there are different species and they're
not even in the same genus so they're
unable to interbreed with each other
they can however or are however
susceptible to the same diseases canine
distemper and rabies being the two that
come to mind and the two that seemed to
be doing the most damage to the wild dog
population and of course because we live
in rural areas out here where there are
absolutely no veterinary services
whatsoever thanks to the general
recalcitrance of our government you will
find that you know these diseases just
ripped through the domestic stock and
through the domestic dogs and then the
wild dogs really don't have a chance so
there's very poor government inoculation
and care of domestic animals out here
and people are too poor to do it
privately so it is a problem that is
multi-pronged
but there are other good people doing a
lot of good work into wild dogs and
their survival and well I don't know how
successful all of the efforts to
conserve them are it's certainly
certainly we're getting a lot more
information than ever before
Paula there is a lot of work being done
on them and the main body of work
probably being done by the endangered
wildlife trust an exceptional South
African NGO that there's a lot of good
work with vultures and wild dogs and
cheetah in this area and in other areas
and they certainly seem to they the guys
I think I'm pretty sure who put the
collars on some of the dogs that we see
quite frequently I still don't have any
tracks here I suspect what they've done
is they haven't gone very far from where
they were but it just probably got a bit
hot where they were and found a little
bit of shade quite close by and gone
sleep
I'd have to do a brief foray on food to
see if I can find them
keep driving for now
now they do den Christy but they don't
den like hyenas do there's a dyke over
there focus want to show that one hole
in the back of my head there is a darker
and the darker is gone that was a lovely
sighting fantastic Thank You dark yet
Christy they do din but for Tim for
temporarily their den for about three or
four months at a time just while the
babies are very little probably less
than four months actually and then they
move on and they become nomadic again so
they don't have a den site and natal den
and if it's a big clan another sort of
secondary den site as you see with the
north clan and in the Mara and certainly
as we used to see over here with our
Juma clan but they do den when the alpha
female is ready to give birth and the
pups are born in a den site and there
they remain I think they start moving if
I'm not mistaken with it with the pack
at about three or four months
all righty I'm gonna try my level best
to find these hounds if not we'll move
on from some to something else jamie has
got some peaks and those Peaks are doing
some exercise well I'm trying to find
you warthogs but I have to tell you that
they are now gone completely it was a
fool's mission but I really wanted to
show you something because something's
very something very cool is happening in
the Maasai Mara at the moment the
warthogs are having their piglets and
I've seen a few things big and I really
want to try and get them on camera for
you you know you just haven't managed
unfortunately may disappear into the
long grass but it work we'll keep trying
we know we're gonna see them and this
it's amazing I remember from the last
year don't know if it'll be the same
this year I assume so from last year all
of a sudden the mass tomorrow is just
full of baby warthogs everywhere you
look most of them aggressively then got
eaten but
and the population must have more than
doubled easily in those few weeks when
those piglets dug so we will get them on
camera it's just just a matter of time
and I don't think that was our time
lots of vehicles at this time of the
earth making roads bumpy
James yes there are lots of martial
Eagle pairs in the Mara the best person
that we speak to with regards to Marshal
Eagles is Stratton now Stratton is a
dedicated a martial Eagle researcher and
does immense amount for martial Eagle
conservation are there is one breeding
pair around little Governors there is
one breeding pair back towards in gear
area and the rest I have to be honest
I'm not 100% sure where they are but a
lot of them he has actually fitted with
trackers that that basically let me just
stop here because the noise of the road
is positively overwhelming and I want to
see what this look at this baby is baby
elephant chasing an ostrich sorry James
um he fits trackers to them so he knows
where they are
sorry end of end of discussion because I
have to get it give us this is an
ostrich oh so scary oh so scary oh
there's another one oh my goodness that
one's even closer oh yes you're very big
and very scary I'm gonna go back and
chase them again
oh goodness I actually know what that
one's checked what is chasing there I
thought it was the ostriches but it
doesn't seem to be looking in their
direction and well the male ostrich
appears to be responding in kind
nope
what are you doing you crazy elephant
Mama's coming up to investigate what do
you seem ostridge do you after I think
this thought I think it is the ostrich I
think it is it just looks odd it's at an
odd angle somehow but I really think now
that the rest of the herds coming in Hey
look at this
that's incredible maybe this lobster has
a nest here that's why it's so reluctant
to move it's not gonna have a choice
though the whole herd comes around see
how it's making itself as big as
possible unfortunately it's up against
the biggest animal on land so that's not
gonna work all that well I hope it's not
a nest that would be terribly tragic
there is a female nearby and the males
do sit on the eggs oh oh so indignant so
indignant not very happy at all when
last did you see an elephant chase an
ostrich I can safely say I don't think I
ever have the absolute definition of
feathers ruffled right up there with a
pecking order
sorry my boy I don't think it's a nest I
think you just happened to be sitting
there and now it's been forced away it
was so cool I think you may have noticed
those of you who are sharp eyed but the
the one female actually had a short
trunk I don't know where she went
George
apparently you would like to know if the
elephants would eat the ostrich and the
answer to that row is no fortunately for
all of us elephants are purely
restricted to plant eating you don't
even see them chuubo
all that often which is a way that most
herbivores get some minerals that they
need so no luckily they would not eat
the ostrich very lucky for us and very
lucky for the ostrich because if an
elephant were to eat an ostrich then
that would mean that the elephant would
eat meat and that would really change
the ballgame because now we would have
between 2 and 10 tonnes of a very
intelligent carnivore and basically what
we have there is Jurassic Park or one of
those movies that James has been
describing a carnivorous elephant is a
truly terrifying thought they're smart
enough to know that we're here they're
smart enough to outsmart us at times
they've got very good senses of smell
they occasionally stalk humans on foot
regardless of whether or not they want
to eat them that's usually because they
just want to squash them Athena hello
happy zebra I assume this is a member of
the happy zebra clan were quite close to
their den site unfortunately I I know
none of them except their matriarch Pike
now just let us see I think it's just
running to get away from the elephants
but I thought maybe it might go and
investigate if there was a nest it might
go to the X I think that female ostrich
is now chasing it the female ostrich is
chasing it this is bizarre what is going
on shame she's running in this direction
I wonder she's gonna chase the hi oh no
she's gonna chase the hyena chaos April
you say that you think we found the
horror movie plot with the elephants and
the ostrich and I'll throw a hyena into
the mix and I couldn't agree more shame
does she look a little anxious chasing
away a hyena the ostrich does chase
anything for the sake of it there their
brains are smaller than their eyeballs
so they really are purely instinct based
animals
I'm hoping that there's known it might
just be that there's a nest in the
vicinity and they're just feeling
particularly defensive because now the
male's back again and twelve
good grief treating the reserve as a
formula 1 track shame look he does look
very disgruntled and so does she perhaps
they are two loves kept apart by
elephants which is the equivalent in the
Masai Mara of star-crossed lovers a
shame he really does look unhappy just
being very brave and displaying
it's hard to gauge exactly where it
might be another hyenas whooping it's
absolute chaos yeah
such a nondescript patch of land I was
about to drive past
I don't think you can hear that
unfortunately
most likely a clan male but not
necessarily I'm just a bit those were
very soft whips as well and probably a
male they do make most of the
territorial whoops but it could easily
be a female as well definitely a happy
zebra though I mean for those of you
that for him that makes absolutely no
sense because we're looking at a hyena
this particular clan is called the happy
zebra clan I didn't name them let's have
a look sorry let's go back to the
ostriches just to see if he sits down
again or she sits down again they seem
to be a bit more relaxed now that the
elephants have passed hmm counting eggs
making sure they're all there or just
scratching the back of his head looks
like he's counting eggs but he's
scratching the back of his head Nena Moo
why do Astra's have bald and necks
I would say that the most of the primary
purposes thermoregulation it gets very
hot where ostriches live and their big
birds the bigger something is the more
of a mission it is to cool down just due
to surface area to volume ratio so for
them it might be or it will be a way of
thermo regulating or losing heat rather
than having all of their their body
their skin covered in feathers so that
they've actually got nowhere to lose
that excess heat and they'll often sit
right in the Blazing Sun in the desert
it might not be that hot in the Mara but
in the deserts of Botswana on the salt
Plains does get very hot indeed the
male's of course can flush they flush
their necks pink particularly in
breeding season although I've noticed
that in the ostriches and the Mara they
pretty much pink necked all the time
they seem to be in a permanent state of
excitement around the females
that's where he was when we first saw
that elephant chasing him so I think
that must be where that nest is if there
is a nest I could be wrong about that
unfortunately there is absolutely no way
for me to go and check so fascinating
elephants chasing ostriches ostriches
chasing hyenas luckily no elephants
eating ostriches because then we would
have been really in trouble and then I
would have had to eat my own words and
then run away from the carnivorous
elephants I still think that's pretty
much Jurassic Park am I gonna make it
good an hour lifts it's far yes I can
make it I can make it if if I try you
can all jump on board with me and just
hold on we're gonna try and get to the
wasp lips
oh I've been up a to bridge frighten the
hyenas likely sorry boy
have fun
I've never I haven't been to the happy
zebra day
I have absolutely no idea what Percy
just said but I'm sending you somewhere
to look at something I think
I've got some of their little holes here
I'm just trying to check who stays in
here but I cannot see a lot of evidence
but considering the shape of these holes
is telling me that these are the
bee-eaters if not the beaters must be
the kingfishers so these are bad nest
some of these birds they nest up in
trees and some of them they come here by
the dry riverbed as well as the active
river bears you will see these holes
there so that is where they go and they
lay their eggs and incubate in there
have babies and then release them the
interesting parts about these birds is
that this birth they don't get lost
they always know where home is but if
you can check up here in the air we
don't have any roots it's not like on
the ground where we can be able to read
the maps but this bears because they
don't have much activities to do every
day all we are doing every day is to go
for foraging and is mating and look
after their babies so and that helps
them in order to learn to investigate a
lot in order to navigate a lot so when
these bears are everytime flying up in
the air they can be able to distinguish
and learn easily and imprint their route
back home and they can fly long
distances imagine the best that are now
in Europe as a result of different kind
of migrations they will come back to the
Juma game Reserve and some of them they
are going to reside by the very same
trees and some they even use some of
their old nest they just have to come
and innovate them and use them whereas
some of them are going to build new
nests so you can see this birds they are
so very much well gifted and I like
their GPS system it's very quiet here
where I am I cannot see this path
they the plant that helps when it comes
to the eyesight it is the silver cluster
leaf when you've got problems in the
eyes you have to take the roots and you
infuse the truth use that water as an
eye wash and then you're going to have a
better sight not too sure if that will
be permanently or else is something that
you have got to do frequently they think
such as a toe polish it is unfortunate
that where I come from we don't have
those kind of things but years here in
Africa in particulars of Africa
we do have some of the tribes that
believe on things such as topless so
unfortunately in Vanda we don't have to
collage we don't believe under polish so
a Tokoloshe I am NOT very sure what kind
of an animal it is but I have here that
is something that causes quite a lot of
problems but in vendor they are anti
anti Tokoloshe plants so some of the
people who are experiencing problems
with topologies from different tribes
they come to vendor as well in order to
be assisted to chase away those kind of
of spirits
now while I'm trying to look for other
small things
let's see James is busy trying to find
you the wild dogs you know I failed to
find them and I've just chatted to
Rick's on the radio and there were a
whole lot of them calling around the
campus late this morning or late ish
this morning and I wonder if these guys
can go and try and find those guys all
there's just insufficient shade here and
they've moved into a shady area so we're
gonna go down towards the water hole
near camp see what's going on there
and then we'll probably make our way
back to the lip odds as the day starts
to draw to a close along with the week
bringing the week to a close of course
anyway there's what we're doing now now
to apologize mine competence at finding
him you can stack a little drone into
the air to see if we could see them but
alas we could not then know where
they've gone so very few signs of spring
just yet but the not formed trees er on
campus started to flower which is very
nice casting a gentle and honey scented
air around the place mingles quite
nicely with a septic tank outside my
window
couldn't resist that sorry
it's not too bad I promise alright let's
fasten biology
there's a stony silence from the final
control at the moment I believe I like
got off the car to go and look for the
wild dogs on foot
Fergus says to me the hyenas archana
what the ostrich is chasing the hyena
that's not something you say every day
really it's not something you hear
someone say every day so something you
see every day ostriches chasing hyenas
must have been quite fun
elephants chasing ostriches you know I
haven't seen anything like that over
here
weekend escape you're wondering about
assault clicks and whether Juma has any
salt licks on it or not no there are no
salt licks that are unmanned made or
there are no man-made salt dick sorry
there are some areas that have so dicks
oil so they're clay rich and they retain
quite a lot of salt and those areas are
on the rivers so as soon as you get near
a river there's a gin general sort of
movement of clay down the slope towards
the rivers and there you will find soil
that animals certainly do eat from time
to time especially at this time of the
year when they're but short of the
nutrients and you'd call that a soda
carrier and yeah I've tried to eat I've
tried to taste any sort of salt in it
failed dismally is a little bit like
eating beach sand which of course is
work not delicious
likewise the sand that the termites
would put on the trees is a huge via
edible thing for a lot of people out
here but I've never managed to stomach
it has been another interesting one to
ask Sydney actually I forgot to ask him
asking movies the termites and I think
there's some dog tracks on the road here
which is quite nice
it's quite exciting
Paula no wild dogs are unlike leopards
and unlike hyenas they are sort of not
suspicious of but they will try and
avoid human beings more than those two
creatures will we've had them very very
close to camp before we've had them
coming right past the tent
we've had them coming right past the
entrance to the camp and so they they
will come close to camp but I don't
think you'll find they would ever
actually come into it and this they've
got sort of lost as these ones certainly
do there was that mournful wailings
while this morning when I woke up and
that was not the sound of any of the
crew sporting vicious hangovers after
their ref party last night but that of a
wild dog calling trying to locate its
friends oh yes I'm in parlor let's stop
and give them a little bit of
consideration given that I haven't shown
you any animals for some time
hello you definitely wouldn't be looking
quite as cheerful as you are if you'd
seen a wild dog I'll bet you know you
wouldn't see the light is now starting
to soften beautifully very nice relaxing
Sunday scene of Impala grazing somehow
managing to derive nutrients from these
dry conditions
I suspect they've just been for a drink
at the Gallagher waterhole they're all
sort of heading out of that area yes
that's you I'm talking about quite
surprised aren't you mm-hmm
very surprised all the time in parlors
they have to be oh my goodness Tristan
is de about to do his second segment of
the afternoon let's go across to him
immediately well we are James have been
doing it with one thing that we don't
really see very often staying for long
periods of time and that's birds and so
really nice to have a flock of guinea
fowls that have come down for a late
evening drink they are birds that do
drink quite regularly and we see them
fairly often around quarantine and the
dam area and they kind of scuttle about
looking for food and I can say every now
and then will come in for a drink and
they generally are in quite big groups
together this one is only the three that
I can see so far there's the king of the
castle now that's decided I'm going to
sit on top it would be interesting to
see if it actually started to call now
of course we don't have audio on the
nest cams but it will be interesting to
see if it beats mood if the beak moves
while it's sitting on top there because
often when Birds go onto a ridge like
this especially ground-dwelling Birds
this is a place that they'll end up
making a territorial call or just
vocalizing to let everybody know that
they are in charge but you can see
there's quite a few of them actually
kind of coming out from behind that
mound and they hopefully are all gonna
come and start drinking they're an
incredible bird though we don't you know
we obviously see them quite often in
very regular you just drive past them
because they are quite common but they
really are very very unique looking with
that big helmets that is on top hence
the name helmeted guinea fowl and then
the very bright colors is apart and
quite interesting patterned feathers oh
there's a bit of stretching going on
it's yoga it's yoga at the dam this
afternoon with the one on the right is
there a little wing stretch and legs
stretch now Chris you say it's African
chickens yes they are but like African
chickens aren't there they're about as
bright as chickens too I will say one
thing though they are quite valuable for
us
outch here because a quite a reliable
bird for alarm call so when you hear
these guys alarm calling you know that
there is something around the problem is
is that they will alarm call for birds
of prey as well but you will see them
alarm calling for leopard and lions and
wild dogs and all those kind of things
so they're actually not the worst thing
to have around because they pretty keen
sighted and if you find them flying up
into the tree and alarm calling well
then you know very quickly that there is
something around the thing is though
there is a time in the year where they
do make a lot of noise that sounds like
a long calls but that's during their
breeding period and that's normally sort
of summer time so early summer you find
these guys make quite a racket they're
very very cool to see in you know you
would never really get this normally
because they're quite skittish so even
if we were sitting there in a vehicle I
don't think they would actually drink if
we were there anyway we'll keep watching
we'll keep seeing what's coming down I'm
hoping for a dog or a cat that will come
down in the late afternoon Sun and so
while we wait patiently did send you
back across to Sydney who's once again
looking at the smaller things on bush
walk I have got one of the very most
interesting animals this is an arachnid
I have got a spider right in the hole I
can't see the spider but let's look
where the spider staying if you can
check here you will see this a very tiny
little hole and this little hole is
plastered you can see the inner part is
is clustered so this baboon spider is
making sure that this kind of soils
doesn't enter there so it's very much
clean so the spiders that have to hunt
for feeding purposes they have to also
use a strategy in order to protect
themselves during these hunting
activities here is where the story is
gonna get very interesting these spiders
they come out and when they are hunting
they must have to secrete a silk and
when they secrete this silk this silk
serve as a net behind them in order to
catch those other insects that are
trying to get out of them so this silk
is not only used in order to build the
spider web is also used for
communication purposes when it comes to
the demolition of territories the
spiders they use silk and also the
females in order to show to the males
that they are sexually active they must
have to give out a pheromone coming out
with the silk and the males they must
come and smell it and
smelling the silk males are going to
know how many previous partners
ex-partners the female head before them
and the interesting part is these
mater's some of them if they are not
happy with what has been happening
previously after mating they can also
produce their own silk in order to seal
the copulatory organ of the female which
is called an epic item so they are going
to make sure that no other spiders come
and mate with them after them so that is
very interesting
amazing small small things they are so
very creative and they can be very much
proactive so I'm going to look more for
other interesting things now let's go to
Jimmy she has got a very lovely giraffe
and see how the giraffe is doing in Mara
Jaime with a giraffe and some somewhat
disappointing news I'm sorry I can't go
to waffles den today the there are
currently other people there so we're
going to give them their space and allow
them to do their thing because we are
not the only people who find northbound
fascinating to form so for now we're
going to look at the staff and I've
asked my researcher friends to get back
to me once they know that waffles as
Cubs are safe and well beautiful
specimen I know this giraffe I see him
often on this road I think he likes this
area giraffe are not strictly
territorial but I see this giraffe he's
a very distinctive very white face
obviously with spots on it and then very
very dark spots I'm pretty sure it's the
same one that I see all the time you
know after a while these animals start
to look familiar
each and every single giraffe has a
unique spot pattern like a leopard or a
hyena
or zebra stripes it is completely unique
to them and we do occasionally get to
know individual giraffe he looks like
he's got a sideways letter K on his neck
there behind his ear that would be quite
useful
why identifying feature and I find it
very easy with Masai giraffe in
particular like this male because their
spots are so autistic
honestly they really I mean Nature has
provided the most incredible looking
texture to their skins it is so so
beautiful one spot looks like a flower
and one spot looks like a butterfly this
is basically like looking for patterns
in clouds only only for on your off skin
they do look like puzzle pieces or like
dried muds that's cracked we're in
trouble now is a full of dust storm but
what the reason I'd say we're in trouble
is that that that is going to be here
very very soon yeah we're gonna have to
I'm really sorry we're gonna have to
cover up I now I just need to get off
the road
woof that hit hard it was just this wall
of wind ooh
we're gonna batten down the hatches and
the rest of us the rest of us drive is
going to be intense let's go to James
who has some elephants for you here we
have some elephant and there is no
intensity being displayed here by the
weather other than the slight heat that
I suppose we're having to deal with but
there's not too bad at all
it's very pleasant it's very pleasant
here where we're sitting with the
elephants we are sort of on our way back
towards the leopards I'm kind of hoping
the wild dogs will arrive and emerge at
some stage that's why I'm lingering
slightly around the water holes but then
we will go back to the low parts but
enjoying a little standoff here between
two elephant they were having a little
tiff over the bush that they're eating
oh that is the sound of the golden
tailed woodpecker sounds a little bit
like Geraldine Kent when she's alarmed
after a wrap party now can we go to the
fear of a thermal camera can we go to
the FLIR there we've got the FLIR
thermal camera showing you the heat of
the elephant shut up
that nice such a lovely picture little
bit of irritation being shown by the
calf you can see they're trying to
suckle crafty elephant herds in Juma
don't really exist now I don't mean that
to be a facetious answer but they roam
so widely that to say whether or not
they're increasing at jhummer or not is
impossible are they increasing in the
Kruger National Park which is the
greater ecosystem that we're part of yes
absolutely they are don't think they're
in any difficulty at all we're still
those that debate whether or not there
are too many or too few but I think what
you'll find is that a Juma you know
they're no more or less than there would
be at any other time of any other season
around about this time they come in
they're here for a while and then they
disappeared Zoomers about 1,200 hectares
it was about two and a half thousand
well yeah two and a half thousand acres
almost three thousand acres and the
elephants you know terms of her home
range they've got home Rangers or eat
ten times that size so the numbers on
Juma vary from zero to probably I don't
know around about a hundred sometimes
but otherwise their populations are in a
good way I would say here in the Kruger
National Park well I missed the
migration this year in the Mara and in a
piece of me is quite sad that I wasn't
there but I'm not said to have missed
all that rain let's go across the
sitter's who has arrived back from work
and said whoo it's hot today look at
that phenomenal sunset this is beautiful
I amazed Juma Game Reserve I haven't
seen this kind of a sunset for the past
fourteen consecutive days as my first
day today to see this lovely sunset
so the Sun when is doing like this is
reminding me of the stories about while
I was still very young so we used to
cook from the wood and you know building
and starting the fire it takes time and
for us in order to warm the food we used
to put all the plates outside by the Sun
in the morning especially if it's made
so that the Sun can at least warm them
but sometimes dogs they used to steal my
food well I'm in the heart when the Sun
is busy trying to prepare them for me so
every time I see the Sun like this all
those stories start to come back and it
works the Sun can warm the food very
much nicely so I just heared some of the
birds interesting bears I hear - quite a
lot of pale spotted owl calls so now I
can see when the Sun is going down the
interesting nocturnal life is going to
take place and hopefully before we get
back to the camp we might see maybe any
of these interesting cats as where I
come from when I was an off days I
missed all these animals I haven't seen
any of those birds
it will be the first time after two
weeks to see some of the hours
interesting lovely animals so now let's
see James is now heading to the lab as
not to show Whistler part
ting Ghana and husana that is where we
are going now not far from where they
were we all hid in there and see if we
can't see them given up on the dogs
Jaime's probably out of the rest of the
show because she'll be about to drown in
the Marcy Mara as I was saying although
I did I don't miss the the storms
especially as when I was there we didn't
have the proper rain covers and so you
just were going to get with there was
nothing to be done about it I did enjoy
once you had batten down the hatches
sitting there listening to the rain and
having a cup of coffee and a biscuit or
a sandwich or something like that I
always found that very comforting most
enjoyable and then to open up the sides
afterwards and see the freshness of the
bush outside a great privilege to have
been in the Masai Mara and hopefully
again at some stage there goes a
Franklin I'm not going to stop Fred
we're going to carry on towards the
niblets
vroom vroom
apparently during our TV show my use of
the term Ferrari Safari was an enormous
hit I'm not really sure why the dependi
that was very popular hmm everyone likes
the rhyme
Thank You Fergus Fergus says it's
because everyone likes a rhyme
is we are not Ferrari Safari now we are
just gently moving
it's got a little bit cooler now I must
say it's this time of the year leading
up into the summer proper is difficult
because the body does take a while to
adjust and as I say spring loss twelve
hours here and then summer there is no
time for it to adjust it's just cold one
day twelve hours of warmth and then just
hot
no Mina Moo there's not a huge amount of
fluctuation in the weather during spring
except for the fact that but I suppose
between September and December we still
have frontal weather where the Front's
will come through and you yeah you can't
get two or three days of I mean I
wouldn't say cold but of miserable
weather yeah that does happen in fact at
this time of the year September to
November ish before the proper rains
start and it can get a little bleak ish
and then you get this very hot dry stuff
coming down into the valley of the great
tomorrow Marty I can see some lights so
why we need lights on the lip it's just
yet given it's daylight now call me
conservative nearly there
all righty let's get in here engage us
like a different gear allow for off-road
driving here we go everybody
I hope you're ready this is where husana
was sleeping on his food at the end of
the TV show on Saturday so he was lying
on a piece of steak
then he ate it but funny already had to
be dead
all right now all right let's try and
get into a good position while we do
that Tristan has yet another sighting we
do indeed this is not a cat or a dog yet
but we do have the obligatory Nala that
does enjoy its time at the pan and they
come around this time most days it's
actually quite interesting to see that
they kind of wander in very late in the
afternoon just as the Sun is set you can
see them kind of moving around this is a
female has just walked off to the left
and then there's a big male that's
hanging around in amongst well Hassan is
a tall sleeping pad so it's not it's not
going to be not very happy about his
house being trimmed away and making him
more exposed I'm sure he when he gets
back you'll have a word with that I
wonder if it's maybe the same Nala that
he chased a few days ago that's getting
its revenge by getting rid of where or
husana likes to hide away and stalk them
but I'm really nice to kind of see so
many nyada's around me you know since
I've been watching this nice kami you
actually get a feel for how many they
are there's lots and lots but to give
these big males that wander through and
have a little drink from time to time it
has really kind of spend quite a bit of
time around the lodge itself and so I
think they come here because they know
the lodge is quite safe to spend the
night in and then this time the day
drink and then off to go and get some
safety no it's amazing also their
camouflage I know this is obviously
quite far away from the camera between
you look at that it's very difficult to
actually see him in amongst the thickets
oh that chocolate brown coloration
really does work when it comes to hiding
arts and camouflaging in amongst bushes
and thickets and those little white bits
just also break up the outline and make
it very difficult to actually see them I
was hoping he was going to come and
drink but it seems as though he's going
to probably wonder off down the bank and
carry on with his day there was a dove
that flew past as well anyway will such
a for a while longer and it sounds like
James talking about her Sanne has
actually caught up with him once again
we have caught up with him there he is
there's husana
he's asleep but I can't figure out
what's played out here 10 Ghana is now
further from the tree than he is neither
neither of them are in the tree
oh they sting Ghana did you not oh okay
I see what's happened here I've got a
little bit disorientated
let me move back a little bit and you
can see him okay can you see him there
he is basically straight through there
yeah if you look the girl left a bit
left a bit and zoom in there now right
come back out so if you you see that
that tree there that funny thin tambuti
in front of us if you just go to the
left of that why can't I see the tree
I'm looking it go down a bit and back
out a little bit sorry I will find him
for you everybody back out with zoom out
right oh I see the problem okay yeah we
can't see him yet okay we'll get into a
proper position here while we do that
let's go across to Jamie who has got a
water back and there seen that has been
described as a nothing short of
beautiful
Austan so while James Rees
pre-positioned we've got a scene in
front of us that makes my reaction from
earlier look like a complete
overreaction because to the west of us
the sun is shining beautifully and
backlighting at these lovely fluffy
water back for us now on one side of us
it looks absolutely amazing to the west
of us to the east of us however
something seriously wicked to this way
comes I'll show you in a little bit but
let's enjoy alright hold on I can't show
you right now it's you sort of have to
look through can you see through this
right oh I know what you can't see wait
there's one more coming here we go the
speed that these clouds are moving it's
coming for us in a big way but I've
managed to leave one side of the vehicle
uncovered so that we can actually see
see that how the the tree is blowing our
rain covers which are held down on our
vehicles with bungee cords and hooked
this is with the window open and it is
pushing against the side of the car can
actually feel Mila struggling as I Drive
her and the windscreen is pushing up the
bungee cords are really pulling I think
it would be possible for us to be blown
over I'm just gonna go forward a bit so
that I'd she's got another vehicle water
back
I think it would be possible for us to
be blown over
surely not it's a big heavy car is
top-heavy though here we go here's our
water box
lovely
this is very beautiful backlit and
peaceful normally I'd say let's sit and
listen to the sound of the wilderness
but it's just wind D hug you say that
you much prefer the water back in South
Africa that's fair I guess these guys
there is a difference these guys have
got a and almost russet color to their
coats and the faster water back though
they do have a slightly different color
and of course what makes the the water
back in South Africa so charming and
appealing is that a white ring around
their bottoms which these water bucket
don't have they've got a solid white
patch on their butts and that is very
different to the the South African water
buck what that reasoning is why it is
that that is the way it is I'm not a
hundred percent sure these are
definitely more red in color I
personally think they're just as fluffy
and just as adorable they still got the
heart shape nose of a water buck and
those delicate features I don't know if
they smell as much because it's so open
here that we're not we often I don't
think I've ever actually smelt the water
back here the wind is always blowing it
away okay fair I mean you are more than
entitled to prefer the water buck here
in South Africa I'm not sure that I have
a strong opinion either way I think this
is beautiful though not much I can say
lovely very soon we will have to fully
batten down the hatches but will
struggle on till the very last moment to
avoid that James has managed to move
around let's see what view of ting gana
he's managed to find well it pretty much
the standard you have ting gone after
meal fast asleep he is right underneath
the kill tree now there it is log piece
of niala still hanging in the boughs
mm-hmm appetizing everybody Sunday
afternoon roast yum yum anyway Yong Yong
Yong ting gonna old tin ghana is
definitely in a state of deep repose
right now and I'm not sure that
anything's going to rouse him and then
his son if I can get my fat bonds out of
the way not far looking on in where I
think that you could easily describe
that as jealous hunger bill hasanah
empting garnet this is interesting here
we go or a boat how far from camp about
a mile as the crow flies
yeah about 1.6 K's so not too far this
isn't a massive property remember we're
never more than 10 or 15 minutes away
from home you know so we're at the far
end of chitwa he's moving slowly closer
I will tell you what - no come on now
leopards do not subscribe to the adage
of fortune favours of the brave and
cause a death often gets the brave
aren't here
very nice yeah he's heads up no I'm just
listening to the radio quickly sorry
it's why I've gone silent look he's
coming he's coming now this is wonderful
stuff it's what happens here look at him
approaching with his head down
Dingaan is not tolerating this he is not
tolerating that at all he's gonna go up
the tree he's very interesting this it's
fascinating he is not prepared to share
for any money he also doesn't want to
really go up there because it's a very
uncomfortable tree but he's prepared
he's prepared not to know because I
don't think an unusual broadcast here I
don't think horse Isle is going to
approach a game and we can't see him
properly
it is fascinating this
he's too he's too fat and too
uncomfortable to go up there and getting
very irritated with husana he was now
not moving
no solids just lying down looking sad
really
I suspect this has been going on all day
long every time Hasani gets hungry
enough to get up and come and have a
look
his father does this you hear him
growling
and I'm sorry about the other vehicle
moving around they're obviously just
trying to get a bit of you say was ready
to go up there and protect it very
special and very interesting that asana
isn't thinking about trying to take his
father on physically they will come a
time if husana doesn't leave this area
that that will happen that the tables
will turn it is inevitable
all that they will come to blows
I almost feel like although this is a
fantastic thing to be watching males and
females and you know young male here
interacting with his father although I
find it utterly compelling and utterly
amazing there's a piece of me that feels
a little bit anxious about it because if
Tenggara loses condition and husana you
know gets six months bigger than he is
now no with six months more ed listen
testosterone difficult to know well how
he will react to a situation like this
sleep I don't know why he doesn't go
from find something else to eat I guess
but he's full so he's not starving
he's eating this thing for 24 hours they
still meet here now it's quite possible
Tenggara will drop someone to the ground
so a little bit like a hyena maybe he's
waiting to see if he can get some it's
energetically efficient for him to wait
here and see if he can't get something
that he's already killed because he's
full if he was very hungry I suspected
move off
now let's see if he goes up isn't it
interesting though how different the two
of them look now that you've seen their
two faces so close up you can see the
Tenggara is much older much more
grizzled torn ear scars on his face
fascinating stuff
I don't think he'd be anywhere near
thinking about going up that tree right
now if it wasn't for his son here he
goes happy go lazybones a lot of people
watching you waiting to see your
climbing price keeps grunting in
irritation and so he wouldn't be going
up it wasn't for the fact that was high
and I was there trying to steal from him
that's great in that special you've gone
to infrared you can see have we no have
we no just a dull day we'd lost the
called--it so this is not a comfortable
tree for him to be and it's not a
comfortable tree for him to lion or
feeding but he's going to make the best
of it
how he fits anything else into that fat
belly I'm really not sure
here comes a hyena hyena coming down now
see how the leopard doesn't react to the
hyena at all there's something on the
ground there doesn't react to him at all
and simply here comes another hyena and
it's simply because he knows that of
course the hyenas count climb
[Music]
I'm watching quite an amusing scene
while this is going on I'm watching two
vehicles full of photographers third
hyena coming in now now let's go to the
year of thermal camera now third hyena
made its way in there we go anyway in
the photography vehicles at five or six
extremely long and expensive lenses and
one woman using her cell phone to take
pictures she'll probably get the best
shots
the powerful jewel was tearing to pieces
I think or far as a piece of the ribcage
Ghana is struggling a little bit to feed
nays are these actually funnies
feeding of these but these chaps have
obviously been quite close by since in
Ghana killed this thing and they're the
unused and he put it up in into this
tree
in fact since husana killed it and they
were here yesterday morning very early
when we arrived for the TV show
and they were looking very hopeful but
if they got nothing Kayal son was just
lying there I can even see him - he's
just in the bush there one of the high
end is going towards him now
I can't move what I can but something to
help us see him
let's get back to tingle and ah who is
trying desperately to balance and eat at
the same time there we go he is getting
some nice things to eat delicious food
rotting yalla hmm all right let's go to
the year of thermal camera once more it
really does give such a lovely
perspective of things I think an
interesting how on a hot day like this
an exposed tree like that gets as hot as
the mammal does which i think is
fascinating
and I know that many of you very much
enjoy the FLIR look you can see not much
heat coming off in fact there is less
heat coming off his roast lunch then
there is off the tree that is
unsurprising of course because his lunch
has been dead for 48 hours but there
hasn't absorbed anything like the amount
of heat that the tree has
forgot what stage to be go to in Florida
all right for now ah now Thank You
crystal you say we've got Corky oh sorry
it's Corky and Tina and heart is that
correct yeah
Corky and Tina and tart or heart tart or
heart heart wins daughter heart so
they're all part of the Juma clan of
hyenas that's very interesting
now our we've got crystal on the line
she's obviously a huge high in expert
I cannot remember which hyenas got the
glossy I do you remember is one of them
has got a glossy I was here the whole of
Saturday morning I don't know if she's
here now
we will wait for an answer yeah we're
gonna get into infrared here we go
sure look at that we might have to stay
with just me until the end of the drive
well luckily I'm not on my own I've got
three hyenas and two leopards with me
now obviously it's now dark enough for
bushwalk to have gone back home and it
is too rainy for Jamie to unbutton her
hatches and stare out into the Masai
Mara I hope you won't object too much to
being with three hyenas and two leopards
aren't we going back to the three year
you can see where they're well insulated
and where they're fully insulated and
we're looking at Kofi Annan tema right
now Corky do you know which one has got
the not Corky crystal do you know which
one's got the glassy eye right so it was
comet a male yes Clara I thought I
thought it was the male I couldn't
remember the name though it was comet at
a glassy eye and he was here on Friday
yesterday morning so he's lift now
obviously gone foraging somewhere else
and part of the same clan these ones are
and they've come in hoping for some
snack to fall from the tree so that's
Corky there that you're looking at as
far as I remember a relatively high
ranking member of the Juma clan of
hyenas and she's named Corky because of
the way she used to sit in the termite
mound in she'd plug up the hole like a
cork
okay take care are we gonna let's go
back to the theater what we're looking
at here
take care is a difference in heat so the
darker the picture like the nose there
you can see the nose of Corky is deep
black almost a sort of indigo black that
means it's the coldest part of the
picture you're looking at then the
whitest part is the hottest part now
this camera can tell you what heats
those are but you can set them if I'm
correct is that correct focus so we'll
change a setting now but basically the
white route is the hotter it is and so
you can see there that the hottest part
of the screen is thirty seven point two
degrees Celsius that is a bar nine you
your thing cuts it off okay so I will
tell you that the hottest part of this
is thirty seven point two which is
roughly 98 degrees Fahrenheit and the
coldest part would be I suppose I'm not
sure what it would be but anything below
say 25 maybe less twenty okay
there's Corky staring up hopefully
and then afraid I think getting Garner's
wylie enough not drop too much masala is
looking on in depression he's lying not
more than three meters from than Timur I
think it was he was just gone up and
lain down so we have standoff tin gana
secured in the tree years I think that's
a very good idea Johanna Tran Ghana used
to drop a meat pillow down for his son
so that he can have a nap on it
unfortunately I think you'd find cool he
would eat just meat pillow very quickly
devour us in seconds and then Paul
husana would be without a pillow and a
meal
ah now from tomorrow everybody I wiII
the drives will be changing Thank You
Paula for reminding us to remind you
there is a blog post art about it if you
don't remember the numbers but here they
come from tomorrow because the TV shows
over and because we're heading towards
the spring time we'll be live at a 5:30
Central African time and we will be
closing down 8:30 Central African time
so you have 3 our morning broadcast
until as far as I'm aware the 29th of
September also when it will shift again
but I have to would tell you about that
closer to the time and then the
afternoon Safari who will remain knows
we changing that world tomorrow we are
aren't we
Gaston are we changing tomorrow
afternoon Safari we are that's what I
thought we will be going after 3:30
Central African time and returning at
6:30 Central African time because as you
can see well you can't really see it
room for it but it's not dark yet we're
only 10 minutes from the end of Drive
yeah they are that's how dark it is it's
not very dark at all without the
infrared on there's no pretty nice but
it's still not very dark and it's also
getting a bit hot during the afternoon
correct polar sunrise drive will be half
in at world be an hour earlier than
you've been experiencing it for the last
little while be three hours from 5:30 to
8:30 and I believe a number of you're
very happy that it's going to be three
hours again well you know we do aim to
please
I know it was a little frustrating for
some of you over the course of the TV
show that we only had two hours but we
had to learn to fly the thermal drone
and I must just reiterate again that
they're the unsung heroes of our TV show
were Sebastian the drone pilot furgus
the other drone pilot and ultimately
patient cameraman on the drone car and
the fourth steve-o for the three of them
without whom we would have got probably
10% of the live content that we did
anyway now we're back to normal
come October we will be doing small
drone tests we think and that'll be only
twice a week but we'll tell you about
that closer to the time because between
you and I'm pretty sure we'll forget
about it until it actually happens
all right let's get back to the fear can
Ghana
somehow is managing to shove more into
his fat sausage belly I can't he see or
sign our property let's look at him with
a fielder we can find him
yeah we should be there somewhere
somewhere on there yeah there is a climb
unquestionably dr. mark if a lion
attacks a leopard his safest option is
to climb not run lions are fast and you
know if you were to put them in a sprint
over about 20 meters I think you'll find
the leopard would win but after that the
Lions big strides I think would halt in
a leopard quite quickly the old lion can
tend to look quite heavy and quite
lumbering sometimes but they are
immensely quick
ooh
pugmark and it's not impossible that
wild dogs should pick up pitch up here
and if while dogs pitched up here they
would send Hasan scuttling up the tree
the hyenas would group and probably give
them a bit of uphill the dogs would
quickly see there was nothing much going
on here and there disappear I think
that's what would happen if wild dogs
arrived here there seems to be a little
bit of confusion about the timings on
the blog post anyway what you need to do
is know that it's going to be an hour
earlier tomorrow morning and half an
hour later in the afternoon that's all
you need to remember you can set your
watch by that oil grandfather clock or
however it is you tell the time
a nice picture piloted enjoying his meal
like I say it's not dark it it's still
completely seeable with the naked eye
but it's not great without our infrared
infrared gives a much nicer picture
and Barbara I do think that Hill sauna
will be as biggest in Ghana one day I
don't think you'll be bigger I think
you'll probably be oversized he's almost
as tall he's not quite as thick SETI
attest in Ghana his head will get bigger
than neck muscles around his neck will
get bigger he'll fill out in general of
add more than he has he's always been
quite stocky never been very tall and I
think that he will turn into roughly the
same size Lepidus ding garner if you see
them together you can see that how much
bigger Tenggara is if you see them
separately it's difficult to tell but in
Ghana is quite a lot bigger store and
like I say he brings his 12 years of
experience to bear in any potential
conflict situation which is why of
course he's eating masala and horse Anna
is not it comes another meaty hyena I
think it's an Tamara turning
yeah well they called patch on her back
that's interesting did a wound that's a
leaf no it's not part of her it's a part
of her part of her ther you can see that
cold touch there underneath her spine
well maybe it's just wait maybe she
rolled in it in something rather
delivered smell Gabi I mean do you mean
do they exude an odor they don't exude
an odor certainly not one that I can
discern hyenas on the other hand exude a
dreadful odor they are very smelly
creatures indeed they smell like mmm
carcass basically they smell like a sort
of sickly sweet carcass mixed with a bit
of dog they are ranked and I think Jamie
are probably give you a much better
description of their stinky shoes of
course spent hours and hours with the
Northtown of hyenas but they definitely
have a really whoa odor about them just
because they don't care they don't need
to be centrist like the leopards do I've
also never been able to smell a lion so
obviously had both kinds of cats walking
past me very close by and I've never
managed to smell either of them I think
they're both without scent largely
all right everyone that is going to be
it a four of the Sun set Safari will
give you a last look at in Ghana the
male leopard before we leave him thank
you very much for joining us thank you
very much for your questions and your
comments on this lovely lovely Sunday
afternoon from the Mara and of course
from South Africa
remember tomorrow one hour earlier at
5:30 Central African time until then
stay safe and happy wherever you happen
to be and I had to have a wonderful
beginning to next week
bye-bye